welcome to this video the first video
covering this year's Tata Steel
tournament and I am missed on the first
two rounds simply because I was a bit
busy and didn't have the time to to make
the videos so what I'm going to do is
I'll do a recap video here of two games
the two most mm in my book interesting
and remarkable games of the first three
rounds and then starting with round for
our do a daily recap yeah this year's
tournament is slightly different from
previous years as it only has some 12
players in the a group instead of 14
players yes due to financial reasons
they cut down on on participants which
in my book is a bit bit strange I mean
why not just let's say put into two
Dutch juniors in the in the a group
nobody would really mind i guess and we
have just you would have one more game
per day it would probably ya know what
the average rating of the tournament a
bit but still it's more interesting to
watch yeah still it's a very interesting
lineup we don't have magnus carlsen
playing and we don't have vision on
playing they still recover from the
World Championship match but will return
to the tournament rina end of the month
on the beginning of februari I think for
for the Zurich tournament the Zurich
chess charge okay let's um check out
games from tata steel white and z on the
first game i have chosen is from round
two it features boris gelfand playing as
white and of course you're very familiar
with gelfand probably being the world
champion challenge of 2012 and
yeah it feels like a top 10 player for
for like 20 years what is playing a
newcomer here like his Richard Richard
report from Hungary and I think this is
probably his first young major
tournament where is playing all the the
big guys um he's almost rated 2700 and
only if i'm not mistaken 17 years old
getting 18 this year i'm not mistaken so
a huge talent of this leaf and suddenly
a player 2 to reckon with really
remarkable about him is too yeah being a
big conscious to other young players
that he's very creative in the opening
he doesn't really have a very
well-defined and narrow opening
repertoire he plays all kinds of
creative openings and let's go to this
game and we'll see pretty quickly what
I'm talking about so yeah this has been
played like millions of times and yeah
what is securing to play now the
Budapest the Budapest gambit one of the
real rare openings in top-level chess
you don't see that plate yep at all
basically the only remarkable recent
game that comes to mind is the game
aronian against Iran shook from the
candidates well Yvonne should actually
got a really good position with black
but blondes it away in it is usual time
travel it doesn't have a great
reputation this opening but if you study
it in some detail you probably find it
this is playable it's not like
completely incorrect but some lines seem
to give white some edge let's see what
gal for displaying he takes of course my
g4 yeah note that this
gambit the fire Roberts's probably
entirely incorrect due to a three you
need to know a bit more than a three but
it's doesn't seem to be a good opening
ok Knight g4 the regular Budapest is
played and ya hear the main move this
Bishop f4 and this is also what for
example Aronian played against even
shook the main point being that this
Bishop is out of the pawns both the pawn
chain if you compare it to the game gear
from place in 93 and after Bishop c5
there's a tech on f 2 forces wide to
play III and yeah this keeps the bishop
locked in mostly why does playing a
Bishop f4 and after night see 693 Bishop
g4 check we get very often this
scattered position this is what I
actually recommend for white against the
Budapest Queenie 7 III captures Bishop
e2 and this kind of position now is
playable for black but it's always a
slight edge providers quite often like
needs to give up this Bishop after which
he is solid but it's not very inspiring
you have a galvan place 93 and after
Bishop c5 III 96 black will get this
spawn back white can try to keep it for
the moment but it doesn't really help in
the long run this pawn will be young
yeah we'll be going yeah Knight c3 here
castles Bishop e2 is this is all very
logical and black gets the palm back
yeah I guess this is this fields very
normal but now girl fans plan that his
is coming up with I don't really like to
be honest and um yeah here White has the
number of options the usual way to play
is actually i think the move
three to fianchetto the bishop and one
black plan here funny one is to play
rook a six and then swing the rock over
to ya even try to her to attack iam this
is quite an interesting setup black and
one of the reasons why the Budapest um
yeah has some attraction to place and in
some cases you get quite interesting
piece played the avant has another idea
it's interesting but i'm not sure that
ultimately it is a good one he played
king edge one which pretty much tells
what what is going to do after d6 know
he's giving up on the idea to play lugo
6 4 the moment why does go on air form
which was clearly the idea after to play
that after King edge 1 as this thing is
leaving this critical diagonal and
therefore preparing therefore push yeah
for like returns with the knight to c6
and so what did f4 accomplish of course
the pawn fulfills a useful role it
controls e5 therefore preventing the
night from staying on e5 but on the
other hand this whole operation did
weaken very important squares and this
means mostly 493 the palm on III and now
really is backward and if I was also a
weak spot in whites camp this can be
covered but the thing is it very often
tends to be on yeah if you start to move
pawns like like f4 hear you you create
weaknesses and sometimes you can get rid
of those weaknesses but in the process
you create new ones this is simply the
nature of porn advances let's say a
white place a form at some stage which
makes them show that this pawn is not
backward
why all this weekend's deform yeah like
would have a nice square after you fall
and it also would make this Bishop very
active so f4 is really double-edged it
has a good long-term idea get rid of the
night only five but it's it's
questionable in the long run and do we
see that rather quickly I think black
gets a decent position plate now the
widest might move b3 of course ruki
eight and you'll get three yeah it's a
problem how do you actually protect the
pond and there are this actually can be
an idea Rock g3 Bishop b2 95 this kind
of plan but we see that black really
quickly gets a species out Bishop f5
like this porn square yeah g3 and now
rookie 6 which is a good idea one idea
is to just to post the rook make sure it
is exchanged and another idea could be
to actually use the rukon h6 to put some
pressure on h2 this can also be yeah
attractive option yeah here white played
the move Bishop b3 which looks sensible
get rid of this active Bishop Valley to
didn't do much black doesn't have much
else than taking not not a problem at
all and all night before just attack the
Queen yeah where is it going he goes to
D to covering III and keeping this this
idea alive and in this position black
played Queenie seven intensifying the
pressure only three and yeah White's
position is not really a Mon yes this is
the problem it's not really coordinated
well
yeah white really should play you for it
and he does you cannot keep it only
three all the time being a weakness this
just makes lots of sense yeah now queen
age form now this is quite an obvious
idea but though it can it can prove very
effective if you want a little puzzle
here what does black players white let's
say place but should be too well if you
want to pause the video and look for a
bit okay oh I'll tell you now probably
spotted it yourself black now it's very
nice move we can take on g3 with the
Queen sacrificing the Queen after the
capture checkmate it's a mate because
this Bishop is such an act of peace
controlling the important g 1 square so
Queen edge fries yeah using a very crude
threat but it's a it's effective white
needs to react to that and he played
rukka 3 just retreating the rook which
makes sure black he cannot take however
Black now has an interesting move that
is the disposal he played the fleshy
move from night c2 which is not bad not
bad Adam he had an alternative an
interesting moves like this position was
the very aggressive move f5 which he for
some reason did not play but it seems
that this might have been a good idea
the simple reason why this is a good
move mr. or let's say point reason this
wrong but if white captures on f5 very
simple black can however he wants p 1 or
queen you want it doesn't make a
difference just may take them on the
on the back rank so white cannot take
but it also means that if I was attacked
and white really has problems to to keep
it candy can play rock a tree for
example but black has the good reply
Queen f2 and this kind of position so
involves this threat only for and white
doesn't really have a great move I mean
if you go away three black just retreats
and probably will put this night on even
better square so after a five wide is in
some trouble due to the somewhat
artificial setup but it played a night
c2 which is not a bad move but it does
not really yeah keep keep an edge for
black rook be one and just when you on
this was the idea quite unusual to have
the night go the such long way to you
want and yeah well black even in this
position now is completely is fine but
the other line was probably more
convincing yeah look g3 played now and
luke g6 yeah enter here it it starts to
get get ugly again for what I think here
why should really take on on g6 and play
Bishop t2 I mean black looks active but
it's not it's not the end of the world
if he goes let's say 93 you probably
need to play g3 get some room for the
king and this piece combination put some
pressure on the center but it shouldn't
be it shouldn't be so dramatic i mean
Bishop before maybe Queen queer King to
g2 yeah something like that but white
has chances to hold here of course black
is a bit better but it feels better than
the game in the game he played 95 and
after the capture on g3 and just see six
it really got problematic I mean this is
just an additional week
sanji 3 and what is why it's supposed to
play now if you play a move like 93 for
example just retweeting it then there's
this move and it gets really ugly now
this is a substantial threat and it's
also threatening night c1 and Bishop e3
this looks funky yellow black has lots
of pressure here how to defend the pawn
that's even the simple idea rook e8 and
taking it and what does why it's
supposed to do yeah you can instead go
to to see 3 but after 93 yards so in
trouble it's similar to the position
that i showed before but now it's a
double porn and the king is not in the
game and the other line white could even
I could activate the King which is not
possible here and here probably a white
icing in big trouble so um oops so after
c6 he played something else he played
the interesting reply Bishop e3
attacking the knight only one and now we
get quite quite funny a transposition of
position transposition of position no
transformation of the position black
retreats his night and now yeah of
course this night is hanging and if
white moves it III Hank so white only
has this move Bishop c5 and now black
can take on d5 this is a very important
point that's now this Bishop is hanging
and yeah okay it should take and now
black takes on only for this is quite
interesting to see this pawn making this
series of captures and now we have a
case where night is clearly better than
a bishop in lots of cases the bishop in
an open position is the stronger piece
because it simply has those long-range
capabilities but here the night on d3 is
just an enormous piece it controls
important squares and it's
God's the pawn while this King is not
really playing so black here is
substantially better probably should win
um yeah not taking on g6 William was a
costly mistake it now gets gets really
difficult kingi 1 + f5 this is good move
protecting the important passer horny
for two I just activates the king then
Blackie activates this rook is also
quite quite logical Bishop to c7 and
yeah it's hard to win any end game
without the King so King gets into play
and now G for this certainly makes sense
white needs to activate and undermine
the c-4 pond and especially with this
double porn which is completely
worthless you should try to play
actively yeah Roxy 6 attacking the
bishop and it took on e5 this was black
the idea now ok 6 back and you get this
idea to capture only two yeah here we
have a critical position again whitey I
could have defended much yeah in a much
trickier way at least he played bishops
III which it's a relatively easy win for
black he instead could have tried to
play before which sets a little trap I
guess a trap that probably am report
would have spotted easily but still it's
better to have some kind of idea some
trap that the opponent might fall into
you don't know exactly what the time
situation was the clocks here are fairly
accurate so at least them report was
somewhat down on time ok before and what
should look like play now if the big
point is if black plays b6 this is
actually not so precise it looks like
the obvious move trapping the bishop but
in fact after G takes a five
takes and now be five um it is slightly
tricky for black you can easily run into
some trouble if you retreat then maybe
g4 and this is this this parts are
captain if black would capture you have
the seat bone also as an additional yeah
force or this one it said it's a win for
black probably but maybe something that
yeah white could have tried to get some
points rolling on the other end by the
way after before black and also just
take here which is the the simpler
solution the nice thing about this
combination is of pieces this
configuration that the Roku never ever
can detect the pawn it's simply not
possible as the light on d3 always
covers this important square so before
wouldn't have saved white but this may
be a bit trickier you played Bishop d3
after which black simply took on a two
and now the the rook is even active on
the second rank yeah black now should
definitely win and he does a decent job
converting pushing the e porn yeah note
that the night also supports the
all-important promotion square so g3 yup
like it improves the position and fights
for its connectivity check yeah and now
the King advances check and really joins
the action trying to promote the upon
and around here there are there's more
than one way for black to win but he
never really am allowed to anything
substantial for what they were way we
raised to 2 to win in quicker but it's
not really essential here we see that
this combined force
with the King very important um yeah
it's really a meeting attack if white
now is not taking only three which you
did they only move then it's basically
mated after a rock move for example
there's rocks at you and check Nate this
is a funny mate or this checkmate kind
of a small tomato with the night this is
black thread so white needs to sacrifice
the bishops no no choice like recaptures
and yeah white can try to do something
with the HBO check check it's a chat
it's pretty simple technique yes to win
some time give some checks but now it's
just in time to to stop the porn check
on a couple of mumbles check check yeah
it was played up to this point and now
I'm galfond he resigned I'm not sure
probably the first game that he ever
lost against the Buddha first gambit and
I don't know when he last last played it
or plate against it it's a very rare
opening in in high-level chess but as
you see it it really didn't yeah put the
black play into and into big trouble I
mean gelfand obviously didn't really
have something great prepared and the
Budapest is certainly an opening that
you can play from time to time
especially as a surprise weapon I'm not
really sure that I would play that
against a player that can really prepare
against it because there are many lines
that have yeah some some more false
character that you really need to know
and therefore there's some some caution
certainly advice but yeah why not
surprising your opponent can be a good
idea
and as we see this player this new
interesting player from Hungary is so
not afraid to play it in an important
tournament game against such a stronger
position all right so this is the first
game I was going to show let me now pull
up the second one okay here we go with
the second game this is from round three
played them today and we have kawana
playing against kayaking so too
promising young players let's see what
we get koala playing D Phi play some he
plays some many different openings heap
also plays ephors wide so very versatile
repertoire kayaking only other hand is
some especially with black he's got a
very narrow repertoire always basically
after D for responding but not f 66 he's
playing on the news oh and he's playing
the the Queen's Indian usually but
against g3 of course we get the kettle
on so let's proceed this is actually the
line that kayaking has played numerous
times and it's essentially the main line
black develops in the most natural and
yeah conservative fashion with castles
and Bishop e7 and after that takes on c4
yeah the caption see form is not really
designed to to win a pawn white can
easily get it back but the point of this
recapture is that the Catalan Bishop on
g2 obviously has no way to recapture the
pawn in the Queens gambit usually the
bishop is on f1 and can easily Kiwi
gained upon which is not possible here
so the point is why it needs to lose
time with his pieces to get the pawn
back and this is used by black
to increase oh let's say to gain some
some other things for example some time
for for development kara wanna place the
most usual move yeah here there's also
Quincy to Queenie for similar line it
makes sure to get the pawn back and here
we see one idea after a six Quinn takes
be five black ass game time on the Queen
and manages to develop his Bishop on b7
to oppose the all-important Catalan
darshan so this has been claimed
thousands of times and this guy Atkins
main weapon as black against the Catalan
yarnell Bishop e2 this funky looking at
the end is actually the idea of Bishop
g2 or the idea is this one point let's
say that there are many more but this is
one point Bishop b2 is not the most
natural roof of course it looks much
more natural to play move like a Bishop
f4 for example or Bishop g5 let's say
but both of this moves have the
disadvantage that they some are
simplified the position a bit early
after Bishop f4 it's also a problem or
an issue that this Bishop quite often
gets attacked by night um quite often
like this um this is an interesting line
but it's it's ultimately okay for black
Bishop g5 is very safe but ultimately
not very ambitious Bishop d2 is the most
ambitious move of course yeah Bishop b6
now is played this is some one possible
line it covers c7 so it anticipates
Bishop a 5 it gives the Queen a
potential square only seven and it
supports the movie 5 in the long run
black can try to play 97 85 for example
if white white now played a 3 but then
if he plays Bishop f5
which is not so great black plays 96
this is important attacking the the
bishop so this Bishop a5 move is really
a mostly interesting if black goes for a
night bd7 type of development then
Bishop f5 makes sense because it cannot
be kicked with knight c6 audion yeah
okay white smooth as a 3 which is a bit
weird at first if you don't know the the
position but if you have seen some games
in this in this opening it it feels
rather normal to have this little poem
yeah why is that it's it's a
multi-purpose move it does many good
things one thing is it prepares the move
before before can be a good move because
it makes sure that black never ever
moves the sea pawn this backward see
porn is in fact the main the main um a
source of conflict in this position type
it very often can be M yeah reduced to
two one simple task for black if black
manages to just play c5 and exchange
those pawns see against deep on then he
will easily equalize if he does not
manage to do that and never ever moves
upon then this pawn can be a long-term a
long-term issue and problem we see in
the game what happens a three this also
by the way um yeah it's quite a good
waiting because my bishop a5 is
something you you want to play but you
want to do it may be more often 37 so
black now yeah needs to commit in a way
he played 97's mentioned and now Bishop
f5 is the usual way to go however he
played before quite interesting
Bishop a five here is a very normal but
the move before that karana chose is
also interesting after Bishop a 5-1
problem for widest that after let's say
queen bee eight threatening c5 and now
it's it's a bit tricky how is why it's
supposed to to play now if you don't
play Abbey for black has be 50 is got
this potential idea might be six to see
form it's a not so clear what this
Bishop is doing but I think this is
probably the more convincing way to go
it's not clear that this is such a great
position at the moment yeah I played
before and therefore absolutely making
sure that black has never ever playing
c5 quickly however black he can go for
45 we will see that in the game broke
eight seven this is some impact of halle
typical move in this structure it
prepares grenade fianchetto in the Queen
but it's also a bit artificial it's not
clear that this is really a necessary
move but what are blacks are
alternatives he could have tried to to
play e5 let's check this after you five
white has got this simple reply 95 oops
95 and now after Bishop takes g2 white
has the funny improve night takes f7 and
this is probably why black didn't didn't
go for that after look at seven King g2
yeah why does upon up it's not entirely
clear though after c5 still it looks
like some wood weird way to play after
c5 PT xe5 there's rook c8 and black is
really active it's not a big deal that
you lost the porn if you look at those
somewhat clumsy pieces
however this is a weird line to to play
and white of course does not necessarily
need to grab the spawn okay but Lucas
heaven is not it's not not bad what
needs to be mentioned actually instead
of okay seven Knight b6 is also move and
this has been played by kayak in last
year in in bike again spittle echo which
ended in a draw later but ok we scoped
rugae seven off a new a new idea oh yeah
trm white went the bishops III bishop
cs3 actually seems to be in news in
another game nights III was played and a
very prominent game in last year's
london candidates cards and played 93
against our own young 93 queen aids and
night to h4 was the continuation and it
very quickly petered out to draw it was
a very very dull game actually okay so
Bishop dc-3 is Carolina's new idea and
it it makes some sense i mean this
bishop on c3 now controls the important
the five square so that if I've is not
easily played and 92 85 white gets those
two moves in he's in really good shape
so on black needs to react to that and
he better do that now Bishop before a
good move attacking the Queen and making
sure that 92 e for us not coming we move
away and clean it very logical night bd2
and black puts it back of course you
cannot allow try to take this all in
pawn bishop so we need to retreat and
now Quincy to we are now we have a
situation where white is pretty close to
playing e-form so black needs to be be a
cautious about
Knight b6 make sense looking and those
two week and squares and at the moment
the control over issue is completely
sufficient now nitey one now is a threat
and blacker needs to react to that he
responds with night a form which is an
interesting way to play now after efore
black can take one c3 and winds upon
after taking you can just recapture here
and plug as a pawn up quite funny and
after Queen takes there's just this
capture and black it sir yeah winning
upon and also enjoys the huge positional
edge so just the blunder after ninety
four white needs to react and he plates
night be three this is the change of
plan I mean white early am acknowledges
that he will not be able to play e-form
but night b3 is a useful move it looks
at two important squares and you know
black with all those ideas there are
nice Queen a 8th and 9th way for he
still has not solved his issues with the
pawns he has not played c5 he has not
played a five and he has not played five
so ultimately the structure is unchanged
and if you imagine on this structure
with the different material distribution
it can easily be a very tricky for black
and we see that that in the game let not
play Bishop to you for after which white
recaptured Queen a4a Queenie for and
rook a tool so it is a question now what
should like do now here yeah I don't
really like the move to be honest but
it's not it's not easy to play of
but I don't really like what he's doing
now here he takes on c3 with this night
and I understand that the bishop on c3
is not and a piece that is yeah it's
hurting black very much at the moment
but it it influences very important
squares at ya it still doesn't feel like
a great piece yeah well he took it he
took it because he wants to play a five
but I'm not sure about that at all if
this is so so helpful after Knight f3
now black is essentially forced to take
on d4 because of the pressure only five
and that he also needed to play e5 if
you give white some time so let's say
93-95 rope here he will slowly but
surely put pressure on the pawns
especially c7 of course so you need to
do something so if I if is very
understandable but if you look at this
Knight f3 it now a taxi five black needs
to take and now the night takes and now
we see that a very important motif is
entering the position or as introduced
in the position and this is a very
typical feature of this kettle on porn
structure when black is not managing to
push c5 it will be very important to
fight an SS if you're black to fight the
idea of a night appearing on c6 a knight
on c6 is just an absolutely devastating
piece it controls be 8 d 8 a-5 so it
freezes the whole structure and
controlled so many important square that
it's really really ugly and black
somehow the drifts into into this type
of position now I don't really like the
sequence of taking on c3 and playing e5
it looks logical but
it reads like black ass is getting into
trouble here we see just a couple of
moves later that rather nightmarish
position is really emerging rook c295
and queen earth Rihanna Blackie really
needs to exchange Queens no no way to
avoid it and this is also not not what
you want to do really okay let's advance
a couple of moves and we see this square
is one important the night only five is
very useful it covers the importancy
foursquare so night c4 is not an option
and note that this Bishop 1d6 it's only
really a good for protecting submit its
not attacking anything and cannot easily
move where c 7 s just lost if you move
it so it's just a very passive position
but i think that koala is now playing
him in a really excellent really
excellent fashion it's not so difficult
for playoff his his strength but it's so
very nice to see how he does it in in a
very very slow manner he pushes his King
side majority note that this ultimately
is the the second Trump that that white
can can use he's got four points against
three pawns and while these pawns can
actually advance and be a gap is able to
get a passer at the end those three
pawns against two points will never be
the factor as black can now apply c5 and
in fact we see rather quickly that
couple of moves later yeah note you
always need to block the sepan just make
sure that it is never moving that this
has an additional idea tying the night
on b6 and whitis has lots of time you
just need to does not need to rush in
any anyway yeah
yeah all the time in the world yeah very
important at the end you want to advance
the pawns so let's see if it so f1 black
can just sit and wait no way to move
anything active yeah and now at the end
you're preparing and white is preparing
to to sink a knight on c6 check and here
we go look at this night it completely
kills off blacks position this rook it
cannot oppose on the default it cannot
move we can I only can only go to see
eight at the moment and the knight on c6
is just yeah obviously stopping the bond
if like if like ass no active play
whatsoever it is terrible after Knight
a5 you're even covering c4 so that night
c4 is no no idea and yeah White's play
now is after all this really careful and
thorough preparation White's play now
seems extremely easy but this is because
it is so nicely prepared right now just
needs to push the pawns on the King side
this is why black played at five this
maybe is not the best defense but it's
very difficult to give some advice to
black because you're so passive after
g4y it opens up the position chatham
it's it's really easy now for what just
advancing and using the big advantage in
space this being the next threat like
needs to to cover that but you can still
just push the pawns yeah check yeah this
is of course desperation but what what
does Plex move I mean it's it's almost
suks won it it's this additional idea if
black moves the night for example you
just play a play it like that and here
it's a it's a question you can even even
go here
get this into into the game but that's
also c7 hanging yeah black black place
this desperation chat still it's it's a
piece now and yeah Kara wanna has no
trouble to convert especially because
this is such a ridiculously bedrock it
can be a only activated via aid but this
this leads to losses on the queenside
yeah Kyle can actually play to plate
this on for a while quite a quite
surprisingly because this really zero
chance or fourth check of rescue check
and only after a couple more check check
get in fact after that he know he
actually resigned yeah rookie one kinky
193 winning the rook which is white with
two extra nights two extra nights and 22
points so a very very nice strategical
display by kawana and somewhat of a
model game the the tricky thing of
course is it's a quite clear if you look
at let's say this position of I mean
it's very obvious for full player of
kayaking strength and also for weaker
players that black isn't in big trouble
here but slowly managed to yeah he got
into this position and I'm not one
hundred percent sure because my the time
I could dedicate to analyze the game is
limited of course but to be honest I
don't like this transformation much
woody five because it really gets white
slides into the game and this really
oops this is controller was a 6cm it's
really am becoming the the most the most
annoying factor in the position I think
black probably shouldn't shouldn't take
on c3 enter and then play a five but
very difficult
difficult to play after that with white
having such a nice edge um black gum is
in big trouble but karana played it in
excellent way never ever allowing any
any sort of counter play yeah I hope you
enjoyed those two games of the Tata
Steel tournament they have been some
some more interesting ones but okay time
is limited i don't want to do it to our
video so um I think it's good to just
have two games and in some some detail
alright thanks for watching I'll be back
soon with the regular coverage of the of
the the next individual rounds when I
will look at briefly at all games thanks
for watching